okay now so here's an example take a
derivative of x cubed minus 10x squared
plus 40x that's going to be 3x squared
you put the tree in front and you reduce
the power of X by 1 and here it's going
to be minus 20 that's you take the two
and you x minus 10 so that's minus 20 x
to the power of one and that's just
going to be plus 40 okay so you've got
three x squared minus 20x plus 40 okay
okay okay so so let's talk a little bit
about interpretation here you have a
polynomial to order three okay and so
Kathy asked me a question in the break
about how I ended up with a
weird-looking cost function based on
some cost function that I had put up
okay and so I just want you to get a
sense of the rules that i was using
because it's sort of rules of thumb but
you'll find them useful okay now and and
i'm only speaking about it relatively
quickly here but in the the website
resources that i gave you last time in
particular the sea / math resources
where there are detailed notes on all of
this you'll find a section on different
kinds of non-linear
functions and one of those will be
polynomials of order to order three and
so on and there you'll see some graphs
so you can follow up further on it but
in particular a a polynomial of order
one is usual is a linear function okay
that for example 2x plus 1 that may not
be quite right in fact this is probably
2x minus 1 right ok that's a polynomial
of order 1 a polynomial of order to
might look like this
okay what's the difference between the
two expressions the highest the highest
power of X here is to the highest power
of X here is one okay now a polynomial
of order 3 which is what my cost
function looked like will look like this
and so that'll be something like
ok
yes
in my definition of convexity in
concavity I actually didn't use the
full-blown mathematical definition to in
order to simplify things in particular
you call a function convex or concave
not over its entire domain but just for
an interval so if it is monotonically
increasing in an interval then its
convex in that interval so along this
part along all of this it's con its
convex and along here it's concave ok so
so you know for more complicated
functions if they'll be concave and
convex it for different intervals ok so
that's a very good question
okay okay so we wanted to interpret this
example we had here a polynomial to
order three it'll look something like
that and the nature of our
differentiation remember that when I
take this derivative I end up with
something that is an expression that
gives me a polynomial to order to okay
so that means that if I start out with a
polynomial like that and I take its
derivative then the derivative will look
something like that okay simplify and
and the derivative of this will be a
straight line and so on so that's why I
was saying earlier that you know many
functions that we could construct just
randomly for often we would construct
them this way as polynomials of higher
degree you would you simply take
derivatives to get to a straight line
you know and that's and many many
complex scientific models are built that
way they're simply you know they're
there are you know because usually when
we build these models we are building
from simple building blocks for example
we think that there might be some linear
relationship between you know we
generally so if you think about one of
the things that I'm interested in is
whether derivatives and sorry actually
that's not a good example because I was
think that weather derivatives there are
different kinds of directions I was
thinking of financial derivatives not
calculus but so let's say you want to
model something like precipitation
precipitation is not generally a linear
function of any
but so it but it but different pieces of
it different building blocks might be
linear functions you you know when you
build a climate model you might think
that whether or not the monsoon will
come before a certain high pressure
system develops over the Indian Ocean is
a linear function and so that peace will
be linear but that plus some other
linear piece put together interactive
might not be linear and when you build a
model it might end up looking
approximately like this but then when
you start to take derivatives on
different dimensions you'll end up with
linearity because you'll have and even
if you don't know exactly how the model
has started their thought process just
by taking derivatives you'll get to an
approximate relationship okay so that's
yes yes through the mathematical
calculation yeah it would be usually
this these will be multivariate
functions so it wouldn't you wouldn't
really even have a girl I mean it would
be a multi-dimensional gruff you'd have
to take a single section through and
then you'd get a graph and it would be
you you wouldn't do it that way
basically right ok ok so now so we get a
somewhat simpler you know a polynomial
of lower order and you and then this
this funk this functional relationship
simply tells you the slope of the
original function for whatever values of
X so this was devidas question earlier
about you know I didn't get why the
derivative what happens if i plug the
value of 5 back into the derivative well
it simply gives me
the slope of the original equation so if
i plug the value of 3 into this equation
it'll give me the slope of that equation
ok ok ok and you could actually just do
that numerically so the rule that you
saw that that you're used to is the the
power rule but not the general power
rule ok so if you take something like 5x
cubed it's derivative is 15x squared
you're taking three multiplying it by 5
times X to the power less than 3 1 less
than three ok that's when X is
multiplied by a constant multiple 5 but
suppose that X is multiplied not by a
constant but by another function ok
suppose that instead of 5x cubed I had I
had let's say X to take the square root
of x times X cubed ok there are multiple
ways you could do this but one useful
rule to keep in mind is the general
power rule which is if you have a
function that says if you have a
function on the inside and you raise
that whole function to the power n then
the derivative you
put the end in front of the overall
function you keep that overall
functional form you take n minus 1 then
you take the derivative of the inside
function you multiply it by itself okay
and you could apply that rule if I just
had five here you could still apply that
rule you could think of five as a
function what's the derivative of the
function 50 okay and so you could just
think of that dropping away but so let's
suppose that we we do an example where
we've got G of X let's say g of x is
equal to the square root of x okay and
we've got the larger function being
raised to the power 3 so i have to find
the derivative of the function
okay so that one way you could do it if
you remember your laws of exponents is
how do you express this X to the half
right so this would be X to the half so
if you take the brackets out to be half
times three so there'll be three halves
which is really x to the three halves
then you take the treehouse put it in
front minus three-halves minus 1 and so
on you could do it that way or you could
use this approach which says that you're
going to take the n that's the three
times the inside function then 3-1 okay
times the derivative of the inside
function and here what's the derivative
of the inside function well that's minus
half x to the minus three-halves right
because the inside function is really x
to the half so that becomes oh sorry
that becomes half x to the minus half
saree good catch that's right okay so
this is one step that's how I get this x
this thing that's just a two and this is
going to boil down this is just X to the
half so again you could do half times
two that would just be one and you
couldn't boil this down because it's
still going to be minus a half so you'll
have an X here and X to the minus half
so be something like x over the square
root of x times the coefficient okay
this this stuff clearly some of you are
familiar with it others it's going to be
new for you you're not really going to
use it in the economics classes you may
use it a little bit in some of the
science classes but you're not going to
use it in the way that involves you
having to memorize any of it in other
words you have to know that these rules
exist and you have to know that if
you're faced with a problem where you
have to take a derivative and it has a
certain amount of complexity then you'll
want to use these rules so I'm going to
just go ahead quickly through some of
them so that we can get to the
multivariate pod which is actually
conceptually a little bit more
complicated but
requires that you know this okay and if
you like you can do the examples that
I've given you on how to employ this so
here here is actually a slightly easier
version where the inside function is 2x
plus 3 as opposed to X cubed okay and
you use the power rule you work out the
outside derivative and you work out the
inside derivative and you multiply that
times that to get you the final answer
okay you've seen the constant multiple
rule you know the sum rule okay the
product rule is something you should you
should see or know about because you'll
see this a lot often you have a function
that's the product of two functions well
you could multiply out the two functions
and then take derivatives term by term
but sometimes as you know when you
multiply out a function or when you
multiply out a product with many terms
it'll look significantly more
complicated than when it is kept in
factored form in fact very often you
spend your time simplifying inter
factored form right so you don't want to
have to multiply that out before you
take a derivative that's why the product
rule is useful the derivative of that
product function f prime is the
derivative of G times the function h
plus the function G times the derivative
H prime okay listen if you took calculus
in college or high school you
this is probably one of the rules that
you still remember okay and so this
allows you to compute the derivative of
G compute the derivative of H substitute
g and h and then you have a much more
simplified expression and you computer
whatever prime is ok yeah let's yeah
let's let's do that example again I if
I'm if I'm just glossing over things
stop me and say let's just do that
example right okay so you know you've
got f prime x is really equal to in this
case the product of two functions this
is G of X and this is H of X okay so i
simply substitute my rule i know that
that is G times H prime plus h times G
prime ok well gee is just that X minus 3
h prime what's H prime for X and H is 2x
squared minus 1 and what's G prime one
right and I could simplify this out if
and so so that's going to be 4x squared
minus 12x plus 2x squared minus 1 okay
this and that will give you 6 x squared
minus 12x and that's what hopefully I
have up there okay okay okay so what I
did is I compiled a whole bunch of
useful rules and I put them on a couple
of slides for you we don't need to go
through these but they are sometimes
useful when doing problem sets
derivative of a constant derivative of a
linear function derivative of polynomial
functions something that's useful to
keep in mind the derivative of the
function e to the X is what
is e to the X okay so this has the this
function is actually constructed so that
it's slope is itself okay so the slope
of this function e to the X is always
equal to its value sorry well it's you
know it's a it's a very useful expert
it's a very useful way of showing
exponential sorry this is this is the
inverse of that function sorry okay so
you know it has biological applications
in particular suppose that the you know
suppose that you that the the growth of
some proportion of a species in the
population is dependent on the size of
that proportion in the population so you
would imagine a scenario where if you
have a species the larger the bigger a
portion of the globe it takes up the
faster it goes